it has been a very very long saga really
almost a decade sort of in total but
WikiLeaks is Julian Assange has been
arrested in London and there's so much
to talk about here there's the sort of
immediate legal implications there are
the broader questions about what happens
first and what happens later because
there are a variety of different legal
claims against Assange and we're gonna
talk about all of it if you've not been
following it or just to kind of get
everybody up to speed
Julian Assange of WikiLeaks has been in
the Ecuadorian Embassy in London for
seven years now thanks to Ecuadorian
Asylum that was granted to him and this
latest development was not totally
surprising in terms of the rescinding of
that Asylum by the Ecuadorian Embassy
because we've been covering for a couple
of months including on the bonus show
how the Ecuadorian Embassy was sort of
increasingly
in conflict with Assange over there were
sort of more and less cartoonish
versions of the story but basically his
discourteous and aggressive behavior is
the word they use there were rumors
rumors swirling about and not cleaning
up after his cat and sort of more more
cartoonish things I don't know the full
scope of that but in one case or another
he now is no longer protected by asylum
by the Ecuadorian embassy and
immediately after that rescinding or
revocation took place
British police went into the embassy and
arrested Julian Assange now we have
learned about a 20-17
u.s. federal court indictment which
charges Assange for conspiring to
publish classified documents which were
partially some of which were obtained by
chelsea manning who you may remember did
I believe it was seven years herself
before ultimately being let out by
President Barack Obama and when it comes
to extradition that's the immediate
question the United States has filed an
extradition request to the UK the US and
the UK have an extradition agreement so
he will likely at some point have to
deal with the American justice system
but that may not happen immediately
because Assange has unresolved business
with UK
first because you might recall and it's
been so many years at this point I mean
it's amazing all that's happened
politically while Julian Assange has
just been in the Ecuadorian Embassy but
back in 2012
Assange jumped UK bail so he faces up to
a year in prison in the UK and this
could just be the start of a very very
long process and the political
implications have gotten particularly
interesting because during the time that
Assange has been in the Ecuadorian
embassy we have now learned about the
connections between WikiLeaks to Russia
and the DNC and Hillary Clinton hacks
and the molar probe and the 2016
election everything that right now is
happening in terms of the UK bail
jumping and the 2017 sealed indictment
none of this stuff has anything to do
with Russia but you may recall from a
couple of weeks ago from the William Bar
letter about the Robert Moeller report
you may recall from my report six months
ago 12 months ago a year and a half ago
that during the time Assange was in the
Ecuadorian embassy now WikiLeaks
released tens of thousands of emails
that were stolen from the DNC and from
Hillary Clinton by Rutte but from the
Hillary Clinton campaign by Russia this
is part of Robert Muller's investigation
and as far as we were told by william
bars four-page letter to the extent that
we can believe it and hopefully soon
we'll have more specific information
about this wikileaks is also part of
Muller's report and when Assange went
into the embassy there was still the
idea or maybe the possibility that
wikileaks was not a partisan actor but
just a clearinghouse of information that
has drastically changed while Julian
Assange has been in the Ecuadorian
embassy we now know that WikiLeaks is a
part as an actor that's not a good or a
bad thing I want to be super clear that
people understand when I say WikiLeaks
is a part as an actor partisan actors
are fine right I don't have a problem
with partisan actors as long as they are
identified as such and presented as such
and we know that a WikiLeaks was working
as a saw
middleman for hacked emails from the DNC
from Hillary Clinton's campaign by
Russia for the purpose of helping Donald
Trump defeat Hillary Clinton in 2016 but
now it's not at all clear right now
whether that will at some point relate
to any criminal charges against Julian
Assange there's a lot that he has that
has to be cleared up before we even get
to the point of talking about could
anything related to Russia or Muller
connect to criminal charges so that is
sort of in a remains to be seen
phase and then there's also the
possibility of these so-called Deadman
switches that have been mentioned before
we don't really know the full scope or
extent of it right now but there were
claims made that Julian Assange had set
up different caches of documents caches
of information which if he doesn't
prevent their release by checking in
electronically every once in a while
either by pinging a certain email
address or entering a password somewhere
the logistics don't really matter the
idea is if he were to be killed or
captured that by not preventing the
release of certain documents they would
automatically be released maybe
published by WikiLeaks maybe sent to
media outlets what is the status of that
we don't know and now that Julian
Assange has been arrested if that is
also going to be a question which may be
answered sooner or later it's also
unclear whether an arrest versus Assange
being killed would trigger it or not
presumably there are other WikiLeaks
associates that would be involved in
either preventing or allowing the
publishing of some of these documents so
that's a really big question mark as
well and there are significant legal
implications as well we recently had a
conversation on the show about leaker
versus whistleblower and there are no
doubt if this ultimately does lead to
extradition to the United States if
anything related to Russia ultimately
becomes a legal problem for WikiLeaks an
Assange there are going to be renewed
discussions of the sort of legal status
and treatment of whistleblowers versus
leakers versus partisan
there's who are publishing
illegally-obtained information there
will be plenty of time to discuss all of
those things but the latest for now
Assange arrested just hours ago and we
will see what the next step is here in
this certain to be this could end up
being a multi-decade affair in total for
Julian Assange and for WikiLeaks today's
program brought to you in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a great
service that i use all the time what
they do is they take thousands of the
most popular non-fiction books including
the newest bestsellers they condense
them into 15-minute audiobooks that you
can listen to and you still get the most
crucial information and insights from
each book and I've listened to a ton of
books on blink Asst I recently checked
out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book BS
Jobs by David Graeber
which I listened to on blinka they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a 7 day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be Li NK
is t.com /pa que mas